who was your coach I got the best out of
you was there somebody that could get
the best out of you more than somebody
else because you seem critical like even
when you said my daughter's got yellow
belt and he comes up and says
congratulations just for what you just
gave it to them they didn't earn it that
means you're pretty critical of weak
coaches who did you have that really got
the best out of you and how did that
person get the best out of you
um you know this is the thing I I my
whole career I pretty much I taught
myself I never had a coach so my coach
was in in my manager was in the corner
not a coach I had some classes of course
with karate and all the way back and I
would say that karate guy Roland Johnson
he told me the perfect technique how to
do it and understanding the body
mechanics but from that moment on once I
started competing in Mexico I never had
a call I learned the ground game myself
I never had said I was just watching
tapes and seeing it and then realized
wait a minute I think I can make this
better and they just started rolling
like I lost my last five away of
submission because needless to say I was
a striker you know knocked the first two
guys out third got yeah he was not going
to stand with me right took me down one
by submission he did then I bought a few
more fights by knockout lost again by
submission then I feel won a few more
fights and then I lost again by
submission my last loss was against Ken
Shamrock with the knee bar
and now it really started to piss me off
now I go like because I'm a sore loser
and I go I have to learn this game so I
stopped striking completely I only did
the type hatch you know to First stamina
four times a week and the rest two three
times a day only ground and what do you
know suddenly I became obsessed with it
I mean I became so crazy I would wake up
my wife in the middle of the night
because I would dream of submission I
would put her in the submission and I
would ask her why it hurt oh swear to
God come here honey I need a burger
okay that won't work babe it's your
shoulder right yeah she said my shoulder
and we'll write it down and the next day
we'll be serious about this 100 this
this happened a bunch of times people
walk in the kitchen I said lean over and
I would I would go for a joke and say
are you getting dizzy or does this hurt
your throat she said I'm getting this
yeah see it's a blood choke you know so
I but I became obsessed with it the
whole house was a little Post-its but I
never lost a fight anymore
you know I lost my last fight by way of
submission and I won my next eight
fights by submission people were
freaking out in Japan to go what's going
on yeah and one for one of those eight
was submission control I didn't finish
him but the other ones were all seven
finishes by submission you see but
that's what I tell people all the time
you know everybody can do this you just
have to do it like I'm this guy I'm
super obsessed I give this example
almost hopefully it will spark something
to some people I was I was a karate guy
so my hands are here right and I start
my first Thai Boxing class well I fought
an a a class guy which is a professional
guy he realized really fast that if he
would hit my head I would over commit
with my and I exposed my body so I went
out with a little shot that's why my
love and deliver shot comes from by the
way because people always ask but it's
going for my first time Boxing class the
guy dropped me immediately I went back
home because my hands were here and I
stood three and a half four hours in
front of the mirror
I would drink a cup of tea after 20
minutes go back and my wife at the time
goes you're insane I go no that will
never happen again the next day I went
back to the gym and I cleaned 85 of the
Gmod and they thought I actually played
a trick on them that I already knew how
to box I said oh I spent like three and
a half hours in front of a mirror
yesterday you see so when I see a
problem that I have I want to fix it
today and if today is not going to work
it will be fixed tomorrow I'm very
obsessive compulsive for that guy but
but that's that's the point so what what
just happened right there that's you
can't teach that that's what you can't
teach certain when you're saying like
who was born who was you know made you
cannot teach obsessive personality you
cannot teach desire your desire can go
higher by being around somebody that's
got high desire your level of obsession
can go higher by being around other
people that are obsessed but natural
Obsession you either gathered or you
don't have it at least that's my opinion
from my experience yeah but you know I
think it came from and I was very sick
you know because I was I wanted the
biggest room in the house which was the
Attic yeah but if I had an asthma attack
that was every five weeks weak and bad
not able to eat because I couldn't
breathe so you can only imagine if I go
down and fly the stairs took me 45
minutes but I had to do it and that
happened every five weeks so I had to go
down and going up two steps sitting down
resting two steps up sitting down you
know but that was pushing me I think to
if I want something well now I know I
have to work for it so all that stuff
that I had that I thought was a curse
when I was a kid it became a blessing
100 100 because that's why I'm sitting
here right now because I got bullied in
all the diseases I want to ask you a
question about that exact topic right
there you said you know basically what
you're saying it's not the size of the
dog in the fight it's the size of the
fight and the dog you said at the
beginning that when you were a kid they
called you the leper yeah right because
you had a lot of health issues you were
bullied like crazy fast forward you know
10 20 years later you're known as El
Guapo yeah the handsome one yeah so I'm
all about self-improvement just because
where you're born in life doesn't mean
where you need to finish I feel like
there's a lot of young men struggling
today with you know whether it's career
whether it's purpose whether it's women
whether it's money there's a lot of
young men struggling and it sounds like
you were kind of in that camp when you
were a teenager what are the big not
fighting but what are the biggest
lessons that you've learned life advice
from being the leper and then turning
into El Guapo you know finding out that
it's done for a reason you've been
giving that by the Lord he gave us he
gave me that for a reason why you
understand that because he said what is
the reason there well I knew the friends
that I had were real friends
you know because they didn't care about
my skin disease now I had real friends
you see so it always has pluses you know
I was always by myself I was always in
the forest I had I could climb the whole
Forest Treetop to Treetops swing it over
maybe five six times had to get out
because it was too far the trees were
too far from each other but that's where
all my Atlantic abilities started you
see so everything when you go back in
time you go wow it was there for a
reason so what all the craziness taking
place I believe future looks bright if
you believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red or black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people weren't in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hats especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody saying future looks spread toward
your future looks bright hat click over
here and to watch the entire podcast us
click here take care everybody
[Music]